the las vegas housing market showing no
sign of slowing down yeah home prices
set another record 420 thousand dollars
now joe moeller joining us near south
decatur in the 215 with more on this
trend hi there joe
hey there you two well you both know how
we've been watching the las vegas real
estate market since the pandemic started
really keeping a close eye on it and
every month the prices just continue to
go up and it's not by just a few
thousand dollars it's several thousand
dollars and this trend is continuing as
inventory remains low and the luxury
market in particular these homes here a
lot of people are looking to get them
and the luxury market is very
competitive as well
the average price of a home in november
was 420 thousand dollars another record
luxury homes continue to sell at record
pace as well las vegas realtor president
aldo martinez says more than 1 300 homes
at over a million dollars sold so far
this year it will almost triple what
we've averaged normally with the median
price of 1.4 million so it's still
reasonably affordable as far as luxury
goes when you look at the western states
martinez says 30 percent of all buyers
are from california realtor tam gonzalez
confirms that saying 100 percent of her
luxury buyers are from california a lot
of my california buyers depending on
their income bracket are finding that
they can come here
buy a house and without having to pay
that state income tax their mortgage is
now covered
back out here live many people are
wondering is this going to slow down at
all well both of those experts you just
heard from there say they don't see any
signs of it slowing down they expect
prices just to continue to go up through
2022. reporting live in the southwest
valley tonight joe mullen live local now
thanks for that report joe the ceo of